los gómez se están mudando de querétaro
a parís empacan sus pertenencias en
cajas rectangulares y contratan un
contenedor para transportar las cajas
por tierra y mar ok las cajas están
hechas para justo caber en el contenedor
boca abajo este debe ser el contenedor
que son estos que luego viajan en barcos
o en camiones para bueno cada caja tiene
5 metros de ancho 1.5 de largo y 2 de
alto
el contenedor tiene 15 metros de ancho 3
metros de largo y 4 metros de alto
cuántas cajas pueden meter los gómez en
el contenedor bueno déjame empezar
haciendo un dibujo de cada una de las
cajas
voy a poner aquí un dibujo que ya tenía
preparado aquí está la caja y en esta
caja voy a poner las dimensiones nos
dicen que cada caja tiene 5 metros de
ancho entonces aquí le voy a poner 5
metros 5 metros 1.5 metros de largo 1.5
y dos metros de alto dos metros de alto
dos metros muy bien ahora déjame hacer
un dibujo del contenedor básicamente lo
voy a poner alrededor de esta caja
porque así nos vamos a ir imaginando
cómo van entrando las cajas en el
contenedor va bueno también lo tengo
preparado por acá dejarlo activo listo
ese de ahí es el contenedor observa que
pues sí aproximadamente el ancho es de
15 metros porque caben tres de estas
cajas está en perspectiva sale por eso
las cosas hacia adentro se ven un poco
más chiquitas pero aquí son cinco metros
acá también serían cinco metros cinco
metros y acá también serían cinco metros
entonces en total tiene 15 metros de
largo de manera similar aquí son 1.5
metros pero tiene el doble el doble de
largo es decir acá tendría 3 metros en
total y finalmente el alto también es el
doble verdad porque la caja tiene 2
metros de alto y el contenedor tiene 4
metros o sea hasta aquí serían 2 metros
luego tendríamos otros 2 metros
y en total serían 44 metros lo voy a
poner por acá 4 metros muy bien ahora
como le podemos hacer para saber cuántas
cajas caben en el contenedor rojo pues
una de las formas es ver cuántas caben a
lo largo cuántas caben a lo ancho y
cuántas caben a lo alto y multiplicar
esos tres números o sea tenemos que
caben tres cajas tres cajas voy a tomar
otro color tres cajas así verdad a lo
ancho tres de estas cajas azules luego
sino o sea aquí que habría una verdad
una por aquí dos y por aquí que habría
una tercera ahora si nos vamos así a lo
largo caben dos porque cada caja es de
1.5 y el contenedor es de 3 entonces
aquí que habría una y aquí otra 2 y
finalmente si nos vamos hacia arriba
también caben 2 entonces serían 3 que
caben de ancho x 2
por dos que caben a lo largo x dos que
caben a lo alto y en total
eso sería igual a tres por 12 6 por 2 es
12 entonces que habrían 12 cajas eso es
una de las formas en las cuales se puede
hacer pero a lo mejor es un poquito
complicado porque hay que hacer el
dibujo y entender pues exactamente
cuántas cajas caben a lo largo a lo
ancho y a lo alto y eso puede ser un
poco la tos otra forma de hacerlo es
comparar el volumen tanto de las cajas
como del contenedor y luego vemos
cuántas veces cabe el volumen de la caja
en el volumen del contenedor eso va a
funcionar porque nos dicen que las cajas
están hechas para justo caber en el
contenedor vale bueno vamos a hacerlo
así déjame tomar el color azul para
calcular el volumen de las cajas
entonces cada una de las cajas cada caja
tiene dimensiones 52 y 1.5 entonces para
encontrar su volumen hay que multiplicar
5 por 2
por 1.5 eso de ahí es igual a 5 por 2 es
10 y 10 por 1.5 es igual a 15 a 15 muy
bien ese es el volumen de cada una de
las cajas vamos a ver ahora cuál es el
volumen del contenedor
el contenedor le voy a poner aquí
contenedor contenedor
the door tiene dimensiones tiene
dimensiones 15 3 y 2 entonces tendríamos
que multiplicar 15 15 por 3 por 2 y eso
da cuánto es igual
bueno pues 3 por 15 es igual a 45 y 45
no perdón el alto nuestros el alto es 4
verdad porque hasta aquí era 2 y hasta
acá es 4 entonces es 15 por 3 por 4
uff casi me equivoco bueno entonces
sería 15 por 3 es 45 45 por 4 pues por 2
es 90 por 12 180 entonces el volumen del
contenedor sería de ciento de 180 muy
bien los dos están en metros metros
cúbicos verdad porque estamos trabajando
en metros bueno pues no tenemos que 15
justo cabe 12 veces en 180 si hacemos 15
por 10 sería 150 si hacemos 2 por 15
sería 30 150 con 30 serían 180 y por lo
tanto nos vuelve a quedar
que caben 12 cajas entonces esas dos son
dos formas de verlo uno es ver cuántas
cajas caben a lo largo a lo ancho ya lo
alto y la otra forma es comparando los
volúmenes